[Music]
all right guys we
are still talking about
the stuff that's happening right now in
the pandemic in this one as well this
episode
so there's singapore airlines
yippee skippy there you go
i mean they know because they clicked on
the the title but i'm letting you guys
what's happening with singapore airlines
i love them
you know they're top three rated they're
great they're amazing
well look at their country is amazing
and the flight attendants they came
people anyone that's a political
opponent they kick them off the airplane
like literally if you let her you're
going to jail they execute they pay a
thousand dollar fine and if you can't
pay it then you go to jail there it is
don't eat you and no gum
i fell in love with my first flight
attendant when i was like when i was
like eight years old on singapore
airlines they're hot bro yeah they're
hot even when you're not eight years old
models well single they give you ice
cream even in coach
you've been there you've been here oh
yeah i flew to singapore they treat
coach like people
it's an interesting way to do an area
that is interesting never thought of
that no
so uh singapore airlines is said to be
considering a new
route this week or this month where
they're calling it the flight
to nowhere because of the fact that
they're on an island and like a lot of
people there they're used to traveling a
lot and they haven't been able to
for a solid five months six months and
so now they're saying that
they're going to be having these
destination free
flying so it just goes in a circle and
comes back
you have to go to an airport with lots
of crowds and be on an airplane where
there's
cycle it's not crowded and go to nowhere
like oh it's not crowded well no because
they're not flying out
okay okay you continue because i'm like
if you're if you're if it's a pandemic
thing and like you know airports are
like then don't go to airports they're
like the number one place like
but you're bored you know yeah yeah
you're bored in the house you go to the
plane but you don't get to go to a cool
destination
some people [ __ ] love being on the
plane though yeah i'm imagining that
they go to the
singapore airport right and then they go
um
do a circle and then come right back to
the same airport
so their their airport's like a mall
like it's like
you know so it's probably that whole
experience
and what if the plane is wearing a mask
that's true the nose i didn't think of
that lanes don't give each other
anything i saw the vents in the plane
have masks on you do
yeah oh i didn't think about that cause
that's that yeah
but they're saying that uh they're
pretty much starting with this idea of
like
having a staycation but you start off
your staycation by taking a flight
to your own household yeah so it's just
to kind of like get you out of your
oh so it's not a package it's not fly
and then you go
to your rental car and you go somewhere
different within the city no that's a
different
part of this article here where this
other person came up with this idea
in order to to do this but instead their
idea so his name is stefan wood he's a
managing director of singapore
air charter which is a private jet
service
that so he said that he pitched this
idea of a single flight to singapore
airlines months ago
the idea evolved and it's it like they
ended up just taking it for themselves
does the pilot be like um okay everybody
about 30 000 feet we'll get you the five
destination where we just [ __ ] left
uh
nice and safe exactly like that the
temperature is
the same as we left it same everything
if i
was singapore airlines i would just go
pass
over certain cities and make it like a
tour
and then just just be like that's
bangkok bangkok
no so that is exactly the idea as well
in your own place hey look there's the
beach you can't go to and look there's
the football
stadium you can't go too yeah okay this
looks just like drone footage
you probably could have got a better
experience and paid less on youtube
exactly
who misses turbulence let's give them
some turbulence
oh my god yeah so they're also reporting
here that
in late august this japanese carrier
called all
nippon nippon nipples yeah
all nippon airlines or airways airlines
yeah all nipples in asia
all nipples so they flew a 90-minute
scenic flight
on one of its flying honu
aircraft oh cool before in the past that
flight would have been between tokyo and
honolulu
but now instead they just they're flying
around like
uh like taipei like taiwan whatever it
was
just around japan i guess if it's a
smaller planet like you can actually see
stuff while you're going
we are flying lower yeah yeah that would
be cooler do you think it's
inappropriate
if since it's just a really fun flight
let me buckle my seatbelt before you ask
this [ __ ] right
if you think it's inappropriate if the
pilot made like war sounds
like
[Music]
i think that would be inappropriate yeah
probably that's a bad idea marketing
you're gonna say more like making flying
sounds that would be funny
i would pay for a ticket for that i
wanted to be a grandma though
the pilot will be making all the noises
maybe if it wasn't a japanese airline i
think it would be fine
how about the taiwanese how about the
taiwanese air carrier
eva or ava eva yeah they launched
also a sightseeing flight last month on
one of their hello kitty jets
oh it's just these airplanes flying in
circles yeah it's profitable
that one was a two hour and 45 minute
flight though that sucks though
i'm for it though because i think a lot
of people just need a break in life
people are so
locked up that's exactly why we're going
through like i don't know mental health
issues they just got so much like
anxious and anxiety just got to go out
and go do something go ahead and get
some corona the ace and anxiety
is all that steve has when we're
traveling in the airport and the
airplane like it's not until we get to
the destination that he stops feeling
like that yeah
so it's just giving him that i don't
like the airport experience the flight
he's the worst person to travel with
what what about it do you not like
i'm too big for [ __ ] airplane chairs
oh so that's the main thing so like
walking through security it's not a
comfortable fun ride it also gets lost
well no but we talls are not it's not a
comfortable flight i picture you having
a leash on him for some reason
don't get lost honey with the backpack
leash the fuzzy back
no matter which way we're supposed to go
he will look at a sign and go the
opposite way
like he just gets lost if i'm if i'm
like at the gate and he's like i'm gonna
go to the bathroom i'll be right back
i i don't i don't know when i'm gonna
see him again that's you guys always
kiss
you know what trips me the [ __ ] out
sometimes i'm going to the bathroom at
an airport right
and then when you're when you're leaving
the bathroom you're at a different angle
so i'm like where the [ __ ] am i
i hate that at the mall i always get
[ __ ] like discombobulated like where
which direction was i walking in when i
walked into the store
is this thing on a turn style maybe
because you're not
present like you're just so much in your
own head
maybe you're not paying attention i'm
the least present person here
but i feel like i when i start thinking
is when it [ __ ] me up you're really
good with directions though i'm on
autopilot that's me
i'm just going so then when i yeah when
i have to think about it that's when i'm
like oh
yeah so steve's autopilot is just wrong
correct mine is broken i live on the tip
of my tongue though so i'm always very
present if anything i just don't
know the functions all the time you know
what you're really like the whole
jet suite x thing you literally drive
yeah walk through
people you're not even in an airport
you're not you're not in an airport you
drive
and you walk on the plane and it's less
than that's it it's like 50 people or
like i thought it was going to be more
expensive that's what we were going to
do it got cancelled because of
covid but um that's what we had planned
as uh
as our um because they they have really
quick flights to vegas yeah
burbank airport's right next to us so
it's like seven minute drive
you don't even drive yeah well before
like for our anniversary it was planned
in may and then we had like
free hotel room stays at mgm grant it
was all gonna be sick
and then it got the world got sick about
security bar no you don't even so
you don't even drive to the burbank
airport you drive around it to the back
where the hangar is
and then you just walk on oh that's
beautiful no tsa i mean they check you
they screen you they check they do like
a bunch of coveted testing and [ __ ] on
all over your [ __ ]
it is fast but they don't care if you
have a gun no and honestly really wait
they do
kova testing on your stuff yeah how does
that work uh so they have like these
wipes
and then like your luggage they do that
they ch they test all that [ __ ] and she
puts it like in a scanner and then
oh yeah i don't think that's that's bomb
testing that's also bomb testing i know
i've done that like
multiple times so they're testing for
bombs and covet all right
well for the coveted bombs that's true
yeah someone might be trying to you know
do some terrorist [ __ ]
if they bring out the dogs to smell the
detector
don't they catch it then don't think
that's a real thing well if they're
trying to detect bombs and kovitz
the way dogs smell they go up to it and
they're like they're gonna catch it yeah
they're gonna catch it and then now
you have it's the one you one-time used
dog they defuse it they defuse the dog
the
well the covered bombs they could
diffuse the covet bomb that's why
you put the dogs in those cute masks
their saliva is anti-anti-septic
and synthetic antiseptic really i didn't
know that
i didn't know that that's are new
technology
they're sick it doesn't lick their ass
because antiseptic yeah yeah
it's got antibacterials i heard in their
saliva they do have some kind of healing
property so every time i had a wound
i'll be like
lick it yeah after they look there
instead of using uh yeah
neosporin i'm like ocean too my mom
would be like you have a scrape go in
the ocean
and then i'd watch my dog eat all my
cats [ __ ] and i'm like
don't lick anything no don't lick me
i'm so glad i never had a like dog that
eats [ __ ]
because i've seen something really dogs
that eat [ __ ] mine did
which one did meatloaf tyson fun
did too yes oh yeah oh yeah he did
actually
anyway we're talking about these flights
to nowhere here
so in case you guys were wondering
singapore
has reported 5 57 454
cases to date but most of those are
saying that it was
among its migrant worker community who
largely live in dormitory
dormitories yeah so they're they're
they're like an
actual lockdown lockdown like they're
like an island so
so that's probably why they're like oh
well we can just be in crowded places
within our own community because we're
they're basically quarantining together
yeah yeah that makes sense
because hawaii's kind of like that too
and then once they opened up
um they had they started having cases
and then they closed it right back
so then they keep postponing it didn't
isn't it like you can fly into hawaii
right now but you have to have a
two-week quarantine
yeah like [ __ ] sakes i think china's
the same way too we have a friend
uh that just landed there and then he's
documenting
like everything that you get in the
hotel room he has to stay there for two
weeks
wow yeah so they gave him like i don't
know like 24 bottles of water or some
[ __ ] like that and like x amount of
toilet paper and masks
that's kind of cool it's like postmates
for free but you're in a room that's not
familiar so it's not like you have your
fun ship
is it a resort no no it's just his hotel
room he said he could only stay
it's like me being in high school again
oh it's just like i'm going to lock
myself in my bedroom forever
are there eminem posters on the wall oh
yeah you could bring your own okay
i think it'd be fun if it was your own
like room you don't know because you
have your own [ __ ] there yeah it would
get claustrophobic if it was just a
hotel room without thinking like hawaii
being quarantined in hawaii in a resort
i'd be like
i could do it you can't go you can't go
out though
okay yeah or what if you get a house on
the beach you can at least open the
window right and look at it you can look
at it that's literally what tips just
said oh sorry
and then you get someone to bring some
salt water to your window so you can put
your hand in it
but the beach is closed you can't go to
the beach that's why she's bringing it
to the
window it's like a postmate i'm just
gonna order one part of the ocean please
use
one toe yeah i just want to drink a
little bit of it so that can go up
because that's how it is when i'm
swimming salt all in your nostrils yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you